macarini was a superstar surgeon he's
this good-looking Man of Mystery a
miracle worker his technique was
groundbreaking the artificial trachea
for people who had problems with their
windpipe but the problem is H surgeries
are
failing Pao was selling a miracle people
want to believe in a
miracle but something is off he was just
so desperate to show this idea could
work and that had deadly consequences
patient is developing all sorts of
complications follow synthetic tra clogs
up the feeling that you're about to
suffocate all the
time it was medical
torture he lied consistently throughout
his career about his
credentials Pao was fooling everybody
professionally and personally M lied
about the success of the patients while
Paulo's patients were dying there were
patients being active ly recruited and
operated on he had to be St for me the
question has always
been how did he get away with it for as
long as he
did